nous accueillons notre carrière du salut
d'atr ce soit sandrine diouf bonsoir
alors sandrine vous êtes la veuve de
mouss diouf le célèbre inspecteur ngoma
dans juillet l'escaut frappé par un avc
en 2006 mousse finira par mourir en 2012
vous l'avez accompagner jusqu'au bout
vous racontez votre histoire dans un
livre intitulé au delà de l'avis publié
chez michel lafon et à 20h dans salut
les terriens
[Musique]
sandrine piau fois bonsoir vous êtes
bien le 8 avril 1973 à marseille où vos
parents tenait un café
dès votre enfance vous consacrez votre
vie à la gymnastique et vous devenez une
sportive de haut niveau vous apprenez
très tôt à vous battre
à 14 ans vous rencontrez le premier
homme de votre vie c'est avec lui que
vous aurez un enfant gaëtan vous aviez
20 ans à l'époque à 21 ans
le 8 avril 1998 vous rencontrez mouss
diouf l'oral et peuvent vous travaillez
à la billetterie du stade vélodrome vous
êtes en couple avec makelele et le soir
après le match vous participez à un
dîner à la villa borghèse
l'ambiance était assez conviviale
mouss diouf et des blagues et vous dites
sa présence est un moment de bonheur
c'est un boute en train
parle à tout le monde il est charmeur
belles rencontres
alors vous reverrez mouss diouf en 2000
au vip room
mouss diouf à l'époque est séparé de
sylvie la mère de ses deux filles et il
vit à bobigny chez sa mère et vous à
marseille à une autre fils gaëtan mais
vous êtes à paris une semaine sur deux
et lui descend le week-end à marseille
on s'est quand même c'est assez fort
comme en relation à genève à mourir nous
redonne confiance parce que je vis une
séparation pas évidente en 2003 cette
enceinte
de mousse
en 2005 mousse kit julie lescaut il veut
faire du cinéma à l'époque mais les
choses sont plus compliquées que prévu
alors bon voila il sort beaucoup et
rentre tard
vie la nuit et puis rêve d'un premier
rôle mais sauf que le premier rôle on ne
trouve pas dans les discothèques la nuit
il ya un jour terrible où il est à
monaco ils vous appellent un soir pour
vous raconter sa journée un peu comme
tous les jours nous trouver assez pressé
il raccroche assez vite il raccroche mal
le téléphone et là vous entendez ses
ébats avec une autre femme après vous
expliquera qu'il allait prêter son
téléphone à un copain mais
ne me croyait pas tu as dit
ouais je viens trop vraiment de terre
gelée mais j'accepte je lui pardonne
et puis c'est la première alerte mousse
assiste à un match de foot avec un ami
cette année vous appelle et il dit mouss
boit beaucoup en ce moment il se drogue
je trouve qu'il est bizarre
alors que vous vous savez qui se
droguent pas qui boit pas et qui n'est
pas spécialement bizarre c'est quelqu'un
de très simple
alors
finalement ils rentrent tous les deux
appareils avec son ami et mousse titube
comme s'il était saoul il vomit il a 24
de tension en fait il vient de faire son
premier avc normes les types à personne
nous parle d'avc pas du tout
il s'occupe pas de sa santé en fait
qu'il est fataliste dit si je dois
mourir c'est merci mon problème c'est
pas le vôtre sipa le tiercé problème de
personne c'est mon problème il a un peu
dépressif à l'époque donc il se noie
dans la vie nocturne les copains
évidemment le jour il dort les regards
des délais des suites à cette affaire de
monaco et au fait qu'ils sortent tous
les soirs voulait le quitter oui je
laime mais je sais que c'est pas un
personnage pour moi ça devient très
compliqué et je me dis je vais me
détruire alors pour se faire pardonner
vous épouser à l'africaine au sénégal et
un jour on compte michel loy d'air le
producteur d'anthony kavanagh et ils
décident tous les deux d'écrire un
spectacle est là le couperet des mares
parce qu'il reprend confiance en lui se
dit finalement j'ai arrêté juliet school
cinéma c'est compliqué mais je vais
faire du stand-up quoi oui puis travail
après le travail moi je sais surprise
vous dites je reconnais enfin l'homme de
même le 23 février 2009 vous arrivez au
théâtre du gymnase mouss diouf doit
jouer
en fait il est réfugié dans sa loge il a
vomi comprenait tout de suite en fait
vous avez peur ils incapables de parler
il a les yeux vitreux il entre en scène
et ce qu'il dit là est incompréhensible
n'est pas cohérent comprend rien et dans
la salle il ya 500 personnes via le tout
paris il se plante il a dû jouer 10
minutes la langue est lourde on comprend
rien on comprend rien il essaie de boire
il arrive plus à déglutir ça devient
compliqué pour lui alors il ya anthony
kavanagh quai dans la salle et qui se
souvient de la vessie de sa grand mère
et qui dit ça c'est un avc donc on fait
sortir mousse de seine il est pas
d'accord d'ailleurs il parce que vous
l'enlever et sous les yeux de toute la
profession il obligé d'arrêter son
spectacle on ferme le rideau
il est hospitalisé d'urgence 25 de
tension
les reins sont morts c'est à dire qu'à
partir de là qui sera obligé d'être
dialysé toute sa vie ça veut dire trois
séances par semaine ça il en taux de
créatinine 1981 alors que le maximum
scellés sont
déjà 60 on devient
on en insuffisance rénale à 60 ça
devient grave vous êtes dans quel état
vous quand vous réalisez ça je réalise
pas je réalise pas parce qu'il est
encore conscient il me rassure tout va
bien pour lui ouais c'est une force de
la nature il se remet il fait une [ __ ]
de patates il veut vous épousez en
france vous faites tous les préparatifs
évidemment mais deux mois avant le
mariage prévu en août 2009 nouvel avc
là c'est beaucoup plus grave le médecin
dit le cervelet saigne depuis des heures
le tronc cérébral est touché il est
foutu c'est mort passe pas la nuit
alors le pronostic vital effectivement
très court il fait plusieurs arrêts
cardiaques pendant la nuit on parle de
le débrancher
10 pas se parle pas comme ça ne font
comprendre que ça devient un acharnement
qui voudraient mieux le laisser partir
et ne pas faire de dialyse
comme la dialyse est vital dans son état
où le veuille et à partir de là pendant
quatre mois sacrés dévouement pas
maintenant non c'est normal je n'aurais
pas pu vivre autrement ouais
vous épié le moindre signe de vie mais
il est inerte et un jour contre toute
attente ils se réveillent
mois pour moi déjà au mois de juillet je
voyais des des améliorations pourront
quand je lui parlais tout le temps jour
et nuit un jeune homme à l'hôpital
j'étais en salles d'attentes quand je
lui parlais geste je sentais qu'il me
réponde et j'ai vu des déhanchements de
la tête et mais on ne croit pas on dit
que c'est parce que je le veux tellement
que que je me fais de que c'est que
c'est pas possible que son état ne le
permet pas il ya comme moi de doctor
début octobre à force avoir de lui poser
des questions il commence à bouger des
membres il se réveille pas comme ça non
je suis c'est très long alors quand je
serai vraiment les médecins sont assez
perplexe ils disent il a dévié m qui
sont catastrophiques en fait ils
devraient être morts comprennent pas et
là c'est la rééducation terrible
rééducation il va rester deux ans en
milieu hospitalier
il progresse
belles choses oui vous avez des
souvenirs où ils marchent vers vous et
ils essayent de s'approcher de vous mais
retrouve pas son autonomie et son état
un moment cesse d'évoluer donc les
médecins lisent et on peut plus rien
faire pour lui donc il va rentrer chez
lui donc ils rentrent chez vous et là
vous organiser
des repas avec des amis il a des vraies
conversations à ce moment là encore il
retrouve un quand il est du site là des
moments de lucidité il est capable de
parler de chanter de il a des soucis de
mémoire immédiate mais tout le passé
dans sa tête donc on parle il aimait la
nuit donc on lui parle de la nuit ses
copains arrive alors là vous retrouver
un peu d'intimité évidemment sur le plan
ils ont charnelle il se passe pas grand
chose mais faites des siestes vous
coller tous les trois pour retrouver un
petit peu de chaleur humaine quoi devant
isaac j'ai jamais voulu rabaissé son
papa et montrer qu'il a un papa qui
était malade il axe avec son papa était
malade mais je voulais pas qu'ils vivent
comme son papa était handicapé un papa
pouvait prendre des décisions alors
s'ils avaient une mauvaise note jean par
la mousse et mousseux a toujours eu ce
regard il le regarde et
sévèrement et isaac comprenez que
c'était papa qui décidez quand même
l'autorité ouais alors mou s'est couché
en permanence sur un lit médicalisé
il est nourri par une sonde gastrique et
puis là il peut dormir 72 heures de
suite quoi
fait réveiller 62 eur comme dormir 72,1
d'achille et là vous devenez infirmières
quoi
avec ce que ça comporte
vous occupez complètement de lui
entièrement ça demande beaucoup de
dévouement d'abnégation et d'amour
d'amour vous savez qu'il va mourir
évidemment donc vous sombrez un peu dans
la dépression ce qui est normal brûlé
antidépresseurs oui un moment donné un
matin je peux plus me lever ouais je
dors plus je le peu de temps qu'ils que
j'ai à moi je le passe sur internet pour
regarder comment ça va évoluer
le 6 juillet 2012 mouss diouf sombre
dans le coma
et juste avant qu'il meure vous proposez
à isaac d'aller dire au revoir à son
papa
jeudi zac papaye dans le commun illzach
me dis encore parce qu'il avait fait
deux ou trois comme a déjà héros chute
et je dis oui mais là il va plus se
réveiller
et jeudi par contre on va descendre le
voir tu vas toucher son coeur tu vas
rockeur iba encore tu vas pouvoir parler
avec papa lui dire ce que tu veux parce
qu'il va bientôt renouveler ses va
partir et là on est descendu tous les
trois avec gaëtan isaac hayes moi ça a
été très très difficile pour gagner
temps et moi et de me retrouver moi avec
mes deux enfants et vivre cette scène où
harry zac dire au revoir à son père
parce qu'il ya vraiment dû revoir puis
j'ai préféré un moment donné les laisser
tous les deux illzach j'ai dit tu peux
parler avec papa et je sais pas ce
qu'ils se sont dit j'ai jamais posé la
question je pense que j'en parlerai
jamais avec isaac ccc entre eux et mouge
meurt dans la nuit
1h50
merci de votre terrain
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu